dr. Gundry how does this differ from
your views can I go over there
absolutely alright so in the plant
paradox Gundry food pyramid the bottom
is actually all greens and lots of olive
oil and lots of nuts and then the second
row is actually empty and that means
don't eat anything and one of the things
I've found through my studies at my
clinics is the more you skip meals the
healthier you will be and the longer you
will be healthy then at the next row you
don't get any potatoes you don't get any
pasta you don't get any breads you don't
get any grains they contain lectins
which are the plant defense system
against us eating them you do get dark
chocolate as long as it's greater than
72% I prefer 85 to 90 and water is great
and this turkey goes way up here as an
occasional indulgence and last but not
least we're missing a red wine and
champagne you should have about a four
to six ounce glass every day but if you
don't drink don't start Mikayla you
follow the lion diet so I know you also
have a different view about the food
pyramid can you talk to us a bit about
that yeah I'm gonna go over there Tana
so it doesn't look like there's anything
here that I can actually eat without
having severe autoimmune problems so I
would completely start again I would put
fatty red meat at the bottom some organs
I would leave an area empty like dr.
Gundry said for intermittent fasting and
at the top believe it or not if you can
tolerate them if you're unlike me so
like I said I have had severe severe
autoimmune problems hip and ankle
replaced from arthritis and I seem to
react to what I think are lectins like
dr. Gundry proposes but because plants
and fruit all have lectins in and I am
or was fairly damaged I would get rid of
all of them and at the top put if you
absolutely need a treat vodka or bourbon
and you
I know Noom is a tool that helps people
to have better healthier habits and to
lose weight now do you subscribe to a
particular way of eating in the app or
do people have choices good question
so not that I tease dishonouring what
the doctors are share about the idea is
the last diet we actually do not Anu we
don't sponsor any specific diet because
we believe the core problem is forming
our healthier a healthy and also
sustainable habit is so difficult so we
recommend to not get stress out of this
focus too specific like the diet we
recommend to form a sustainable habit
that change your lifestyle and will lead
to have a better may weight management
once our user we see more than 5% body
weight drop that's a great enough and I
have seen many times our millions user
base they look for advanced diet and we
recommend to to study and find out what
worked for them as a person reference
I want to ask we're starting to get some
of the slide out questions and someone
wonders how can I find out what's most
suitable for me I mean obviously what
you eat is such a personal choice
because only you know truly how you feel
dr. Gundry any advice there yeah my
advice is you really want to eat not for
this 2x3 inch piece of muscle in your
mouth called your tongue you actually
want to eat for your microbiome your
microbiome constitutes about 90% of all
the cells that exist within you and the
microbiome contains 99% of the genetic
information in you we're only 1% human
genes 99% microbiome viruses bacteria
fungi we know exactly what a proper
microbiome needs for diversity and the
microbiome is basically the tenant in
your condominium and if you give the
microbiome what they need they won't
actually take care of you and so what
goes into your mouth feeds the
microbiome and that's the only principle
I ascribe to and Micheala someone had
asked about whether there's any science
to back up your diet and some of the
health effects that you felt can you
talk to us a bit about the method behind
all of that so right now there's case
studies there are case studies from like
the 1930s on to people who only did a
meat diet so no not really the science
isn't there yet what I did to come to
the conclusions I came to is I figured
what's the food is causing my issues or
perhaps food is causing my issues how do
I figure out what's causing my issues
what can I cut and I went down
coincidentally to something that was
very very low leptin and that was pretty
good for a number of years until I had a
pregnancy and I got much much sicker and
I was
- meat and lettuce and the lettuce was
giving me pretty chronic arthritic
symptoms and I thought well if I drop
the lettuce I'm gonna die of some sort
of nutrient deficiency but I dropped the
lettuce anyway because I didn't want to
live with an autoimmune disorder and my
vitamin deficiencies recovered and I've
been doing that for the last two years I
haven't been able to reintroduce plants
probably because of microbiome changes I
experienced dropping plants but I would
say if you're trying to figure out what
foods are bothering you going down to
just red meat just fatty red meat is the
strictest elimination diet you can get
to and then I've seen people
successfully reintroduced and then I
want to ask should the diet of kids be
different than ones for adults dr.
Gundry well I am releasing my new book
the plant paradox cookbook in two weeks
and I have two grandchildren aged three
and five who've been raised on this
program by my daughter and her husband
and they are thriving and quite frankly
most of the nutritional advice that is
given to children about a healthy diet
of Cheerios or oatmeal every morning
really Cheerios are a modern food none
of us ate cheerios until 100 years ago
Owen up by the way no human being ADA
pizza until 1890 when it was invented so
these are completely modern foods that
have no place in our diet and I'm trying
to get people to realize that 999 years
ago none of our modern foods existed and
and we all need to party like it was
999,999 years ago no you don't need
these foods for your kids I mean see jus
I want to ask
particularly since Noom doesn't promote
just one diet
how can people cut through the noise
when there are a lot of fad diets
they're good question so we are we
promote that we use CBT covenant
behavior therapy to change the behavior
so so I we don't sponsor any specific
diets which is like a hero diet or
something like a training diet again not
that because we don't believe it or we
follow what CDC recommend you know
United States the most long studies
supported and peer-reviewed the way can
manage the weight better
and sustainable because we believe the
user need to receive the way they need
they can keep it and then they cannot
have it as a joyfully so that's how I we
support like the way how we can address
how you consume the food how you mind
your body that's more important than
just pay attention to one specific diet
that's our approach and intermittent
fasting good someone's asking I know you
left some space in there and your food
pyramid but can you kind of elaborate
for us a bit more on that dr. Gundry you
know there's there's very little
evidence particularly looking even at
modern hunter gatherers that we were
designed to eat continuously throughout
the day in fact one of the things I make
a big point of is our ancestors didn't
crawl out of our caves and say what's
for breakfast
there wasn't any breakfast there was no
storage system
there was no refrigerator that wasn't a
cabinet and we had to find breakfast and
if that meant finding it at lunch then
that was our break fast that's where the
word comes from
in fact the French had no word for
breakfast dejeuner was the first meal
and it was lunch and they had to invent
petit dejeuner when the tourists showed
up so the idea that we're supposed to
start the day with breakfast really goes
against most of our physiology in fact
if you look at our cortisol level and
our glucose level when we get up in the
morning both of them are actually very
high that means that we are actually
designed to mobilize glucose because we
were designed not to eat
breakfast we already have made plenty on
our own in gluconeogenesis
so meal skipping is one of the
healthiest patterns to recreate what we
used to do and I want to talk about
sustainability especially when we're
talking about eating meat
Michaela do you think you know if
everyone adopts this you know highly
meat-based diet that it's good for the
environment and do you have any concerns
there so I think a lot of the
information we're fed about how bad meat
is for the environment is ideologically
driven by vegan propaganda just to put
it bluntly I think the evidence that
grass-fed beef is actually potentially a
positive benefit for the environment if
they're pasture raised and taken care of
properly so that's what I believe in
that being said my concern isn't
sustainability my concern is you know
one in five people in America have
severe autoimmune problems so I'm I
figure if we can fix those people maybe
one of them can fix the sustainability
issue but I also think some of the
information we have on sustainability is
wrong yeah I think that's a good point
last year at the American Heart
Association lifestyle and epidemiology
meeting I presented 102 people with
biomarker proven autoimmune disease like
rheumatoid arthritis like lupus who were
put on the plant paradox program for six
months ninety five out of a hundred and
two were biomarker negative at the end
of six months that's ninety four percent
success rate and off of all
immunosuppressants so we have clinical
evidence that sealing the wall of the
gut a leaky gut as Michaela would tell
you is the cause of autoimmune disease
and sealing a leaky gut will eradicate
autoimmune disease and she's gone to an
extreme and some people believe it or
not have to do that for I feel a short
period of time and then most people
using
the techniques that I write about can
begin to reintroduce very slowly plant
compounds which I think are incredibly
important for our long-term health let's
talk about all the conflicting
information out there I mean I'm looking
at that food pyramid it's telling me one
thing you guys are telling me something
different I have what I like already
saved you how do we cut through the
noise you know skip breakfast don't skip
breakfast it's the most important meal
of the day which is it so we target like
the 5% by the way drop that's our goal
so we approach our services for general
population our competition is very much
aligned with the CDC because in the
United States
72% of all autos are either or be obese
or overweight and the most immediate way
they can improve their health is lose
more than 5 percent their body weight
which is doable by adopting a little
more cautious about what you have a meal
and how you take care of your health in
general like including sleep you know
might be mindful about your eating habit
and overall stress management so we
apply the behavior change solutions
that's why we actually do not highlight
about a specific diet because it's such
a lot of information in our users they
need to have a successful baby step
which is most of adults exposed in your
actives unfortunately and sadly and I
have a good news a lot of millions uses
our service new our service users reach
the benefit once they see the change 5%
plus more body weight drop then actually
is deliver significant health benefit
and then they they become a little
understand about how it works about full
resting and about their body and they
study more and they look for other photo
study what works for individual that's
how our our service is working and
Michaela there's a question here about
timing about when is the best time to
start eating if it is a day where you're
not fasting when do you typically have
your first meal so the longer I've been
doing just me
the less frequently I've been eating so
generally now I either do dinner only or
I do a late lunch and then dinner so I'm
generally fasting for 18 to 20 hours of
the day sometimes doing multiple day
fasts but I would say just eat based on
your hunger and I I agree with dr.
Gundry I don't think eating I never
wanted to eat breakfast but I was taught
it was the most important meal of the
day
skipping breakfast has made me feel much
better and then I have a couple
questions that have been lingering on
slide oh one of them that's been up
voted is being each human is so unique
instead of pushing general and abstract
dietary and little plant-based foods and
it just left the screen as I was reading
it but dr. Gundry I'm wondering if you
can speak to you know we are unique so
how do I find what works for me I mean
there's a lot of science out there that
says plant-based is a very good thing
for the environment and for my health
yeah don't get me wrong I'm a plant
predator if you've ever dined with me I
printed up red ate on plants rather than
animals but you got to choose your
friends wisely there are plants that
clearly don't want to be eaten and there
are plants that we've been eating for
tens of thousands perhaps millions of
years that our gut microbiome has gotten
used to incidentally fun fact the
Japanese have the only gut microbiome
that is capable of digesting the cell
wall of seaweed they inherited it by
eating raw fish over generations and
generations and they colonized their
microbiome but the rest of us actually
can't digest seaweed because we don't
have the bacteria to do it in fact most
animals the only way they can adjust
plant material is with the assistance of
bacteria as and the thing that made
humans humans was fire we were able to
cook and break down a plant cell wall so
that we could digest it
and I want to ask another good point
that came in why are we trying to copy
our ancestors diets life expectancy is
so much longer now shouldn't we go enjoy
that pizza well you know life expectancy
really has nothing to do with our
ancestors living a long time most people
died during childbirth or an infancy or
an infectious diseases so our lifespan
is actually an artificial measurement in
fact scary fact for the last three years
in the United States the lifespan has
decreased now three years in a row
in fact I'm a Boomer my generation will
probably be the last longest live
generation in the United States unless
we don't make some changes but there's a
very famous book called how to live to
be a hundred the sober diet which was
written by Luigi Carneros in the 1500s
and he lived to a hundred and two
actually following a calorie-restricted
diet but oh by the way he drank five
hundred millilitres of red wine every
day so sounds okay to me michaela a lot
of questions are coming in about the
impact of me on the environment and you
know you had mentioned earlier a lot of
this you believe is maybe vegan
propaganda so in your view what is the
correct science has we've seen a lot
that says otherwise honestly
that's not a question I can answer like
what I've been focused on for the last
five years researching how to put my
autoimmune disorder into remission was
purely how to put an autoimmune disorder
into remission which to tell you the
truth I am much more concerned about
than co2 emissions so I think if we can
fix you know the hundreds and hundreds
of thousands of people who are seriously
suffering like if you ask any one of
those people how much they care about
co2 emissions versus having their joints
eaten away they're probably gonna go
with how do I fix my autoimmune disorder
first so yeah that's not really my
concern we are winding up right now but
there's one other question I want to get
to dr. Dungy are there any plans in your
view that are okay for us to eat most
most of the leaves are fantastic for you
if you have one choice of plants to eat
today it's the chicory family radicchio
Belgian endive frisée these have some of
the best gut promoting qualities there
is and I try to have them daily the
other really great thing is mushrooms
two cups of mushrooms per week and
that's not much in a Singapore study
reduce the rate of Alzheimer's by ninety
percent compared to people who don't eat
two cups of mushrooms and that's really
easy to do great well that's our time
thank you everyone for joining us please
go eat what makes you happy and still
good and